hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll today's big idea quantum
mechanics you knew this is gonna happen
this is one of the biggest ideas we have
like a previous idea time quantum
mechanics is something about which I
have written a book so you can buy the
book something deeply hidden quantum
worlds and the emergence of space-time
wherever you can buy books and to be
honest quantum mechanics is such a big
topic that it's gonna be more than one
idea but in this particular video what
we'll be talking about is sort of the
black box the recipe what we teach our
undergraduate students in physics
classes about how to use quantum
mechanics okay then there's deeper
mysteries about how quantum mechanics
really is what the ultimate description
of reality according to the quantum
viewpoint should be thought of as and
that will come in a subsequent video but
right now how to use quantum mechanics
oh by the time this hour is over you'll
be at the level of a you know sophomore
at Caltech or something like that - some
mathematical details and I don't want to
be too historical about it we've never
been very historical in these lectures
but we can be inspired by history so I'm
gonna move into quantum mechanics in a
sort of pseudo historical way and the
reason for doing this is because quantum
mechanics is so radical is so different
you know it's it's such a big break from
the previous way of doing physics that
it really is important to motivate it
not just to state what is going on
unlike special relativity where I just
sort of told you the answer in quantum
mechanics I would really like to see why
that is what the answer apparently is
and then you know maybe you'll be
empowered to think about other ways that
it could be however I'm not going to
stick to the actual history of quantum
mechanics too much it's too rich too
interesting too complicated they were
all these brilliant minds arguing with
each other we're gonna do a simplified
version of quantum mechanics and you
know the reason for all this
throat-clearing is quantum mechanics is
special in the whole world of physics in
the whole set of physical theories ever
invented you know everything you've been
talking about up till now has been in
the context of this classical paradigm
for doing physics handed down to us by
Isaac
and others quantum mechanics is a
replacement for classical mechanics no
one before the 20th century thought the
classical mechanics would need to be
replaced it was just working so well
everyone thought it was just gonna be a
matter of figuring out what is the
specific version of classical mechanics
that we would need so quantum mechanics
comes along it tells us something
completely different about the world and
that thing is so completely different so
alien to the ways that we think that
even today we don't claim to really know
the final answer for what quantum
mechanics is all about so that's why we
need to break up the discussion into
sort of the accepted parts the used way
that we approach quantum mechanics and
then the deeper parts that are still
controversial we don't actually know
many many answers to questions that are
very easy to ask about quantum mechanics
so that's why it's so important quantum
mechanics is simultaneously absolutely
central to all of modern physics and yet
something that we don't claim to
understand so to get there the way I
like to do it is to actually imagine a
fake history physics that didn't
actually happen so this would would be
if quantum mechanics hadn't come along
what we where were we going you know
what is the sort of idea of what physics
is that people might very reasonably
have had near the end of the 19th
century beginning of the 20th century
but things didn't work out that way
because quantum mechanics got in the way
so the thing that we would have thought
well you know classical physics right
and again as I've said before we usually
illustrate classical physics with
particles you know doing things with
positions and velocities but it works
equally well for things like the
electromagnetic field in the middle of
the 1800s Maxwell and Faraday and others
worked out the theory of
electromagnetism which is a field theory
it doesn't fit into Newton's idea of
absolute space and time electromagnetism
was the inspiration for Einstein and
others to invent special relativity but
the basic paradigm of things with
physicians or configurations and also
with momentum that you could solve
equations for
predict the future deterministically the
clockwork universe all that was
perfectly compatible with everything
that electromagnetism said even
statistical mechanics which came along
at the same time in the 1870s again
Maxwell but also people like Boltzmann
and Thompson and Gibbs and so forth it
was a slightly different paradigm
because in statistical mechanics you
imagine you don't know for sure what the
positions and velocities of everything
are but you still think that there are
such things as positions and velocities
so it was still basically the classical
paradigm so that's the direction of
which people were going and they thought
that you could say that matter in the
universe the you know the stuff of which
we are made was made of particles so we
had by the end of 1800s we already knew
about the electron we were soon gonna
figure out something called the
Rutherford atom which we'll get to in a
second but we didn't know about protons
and neutrons yet but those were coming
very soon but we knew about atoms and
atoms had been thought of as particles
in in some way so the point of a
particle is this is gonna seem like a
little bit too much detail but it'll
it'll be useful later if this is space a
particle is something that has a
location there it is X and I'm gonna put
a little vector sign because it's in
three-dimensional space at any one
moment in time a particle is here it is
not anywhere else and along with the
matter equaling particles again physics
that didn't happen you had the idea that
forces were given by fields we already
of course it had seen the gravitational
field Laplace had figured out that you
could do Newtonian gravity in terms of a
gravitational potential field Faraday
and Maxwell and so forth show that
electromagnetism fit into the same
paradigm and unlike a particle a field
is sort of the converse of that fields
are everywhere so sort of if this is
space the field exists at every point in
space okay in particular at every point
in space the field has a certain value
and what what matters for the field is
not where it is because it's everywhere
what matters is what the value is and
how the value changes from place to
place so at each point in space like
that point right there
you might have for example an electric
field which is itself a vector and it's
located at that point in space at that
moment in time so you have particles
with locations you have fields that are
spread all over and roughly the picture
that was arising was particles move
around being pushed by the forces
generated by the fields so for example
if you have a proton which is a
positively charged particle you have an
electron which is a negatively charged
particle there is some pole between them
which is a force due to electromagnetism
they pull together they also pull
together due to gravity whereas if you
have an electron and another electron
electromagnetism electromagnetism pushes
them apart gravity pulls them together
and so you had this complicated but
really very rich picture where particles
interacted through different forces
which could compete in different ways
and therefore give rise to all the
complexity of life around us was a
pretty darn good picture and furthermore
there was some unification of known
ideas within this picture so let's say
you have an electron an electron has an
electric field the electric field goes
around and actually points toward the
electron because it's negatively charged
if it were a proton a positively charged
proton the electric field would go out
electron it goes in and you can take
that electron and you can move it right
well imagine that you do move it imagine
you shake the electron up and down so
the electric field here is the electric
field surrounding the electron if you
shake the electron the electric field
wants to be pointing toward it but if
you move it it takes time for the
electric field to realize oh the
electron has moved I should shift where
I'm pointing toward okay in Newtonian
gravity if you move a planet the
gravitational field changes
instantaneously all throughout the
universe but Maxwell and others showed
that this change in the electric field
and likewise the change in the magnetic
field does not happen instantaneously
throughout the universe it propagates
outward at the speed of light and that's
because if you take this electron and
shake it up and down multiple times the
electromagnetic field vibrates it
pulsates and the disturbance that you
have created in that field propagates
outward in the form of a wave and it
moves at the speed of light because
that's what light is light as Maxwell
showed is a wave of electromagnetism so
the electric and the magnetic fields
vibrate and we see that as light of
different wavelengths of different
colors for example so that's nice you
can see how you know something that you
didn't know whether it was a particle or
a wave namely light you say huh now we
know what it is
it's a way you know Newton thought the
light were particles light were what he
called corpuscles he had evidence for it
he said when you have a your hand near
the ground it casts a shadow with sharp
edges the light doesn't go around like
waves do but it turns out that's just
because the wavelength of light is very
very short so light is a wave in this
field electrons which are particles
created it's a very nice picture that is
coming together
sadly around the year 1900 not so sadly
but remarkably around the year 1900 this
picture begins to fall apart and it
falls apart in two different ways
falling apart this picture and how can
it possibly fall apart well we could
question classical physics but we're not
going to do that yet we could question
the particle nature of matter or the
field like nature of forces and light so
it turns out we did both we showed that
light has particle-like properties this
is very big sounding but that's
important that it's vague sounding
because when we came up with the idea we
didn't have the full theory it wasn't
like you went from classical physics
boom the quantum mechanics we sort of
claw our way up very gradually and so we
made all these vague sounding statements
before the whole thing finally clicks
together so what does this mean this is
the phenomenon of blackbody radiation
and the people who figured it out were
Max Planck
I'm very inconsistent about whether I
pronounce German and generally foreign
names correctly or not but it's plunk if
you were if you were mr. plunk the
professor plunk that's that he who
pronounce it and of course Einstein also
came along to clean things up as he so
often did so the point is that a
blackbody is just something with a
temperature okay you know when you look
at things in the world you see they have
colors and textures and all that stuff
but you're seeing light reflecting off
of it there's also the glow that the
objects give off intrinsically usually
you don't see that because
room-temperature objects glow in the
infrared and your eyes are not attuned
to the infrared but if you heat
something up so the clothes in the
visible light then you can see it
glowing and that's blackbody radiation
and the nice thing is it doesn't matter
what the thing is made of blackbody
raishin radiation is exactly the same
for everything the problem was if you
took this paradigm matter is particle so
there's all these vibrating atoms in the
object you're heating up forces or
fields so light is a wave of
electromagnetism you could calculate how
much energy should come out in the form
of blackbody radiation and furthermore
you should you could calculate at what
colors it comes out right we know that
long wavelength light is for the red end
of the spectrum short wavelength light
is toward the blue end of the spectrum
and we have ultraviolet which is even
bluer than blue very short wavelengths
invisible and we have infrared longer
than red even lower wavelengths longer
wavelengths lower frequencies so it
turns out that there was what is called
an ultraviolet catastrophe it was only
called that later but that's okay by I
think paul ehrenfest called it that the
classical theory of black body radiation
predicts so there should be an infinite
amount of energy being given off at very
very short wavelengths from a blackbody
that is clearly false it is clearly not
what actually happens and so it was
plunk who came along and said you know
what I'm just gonna guess not exactly
sure what his thought process was but
his guess was rather than being emitted
in smooth continuous waves the kinds of
light that was given off by a blackbody
came in discrete chunks there was a
certain amount of energy given off one
at a time it was not smooth
continuous it was quantized in some
sense okay this is the beginning of
quantum mechanics circa 1900 when plunk
first made his suggestion and the
suggestion was that light comes in
chunks of energy and the energy depended
on the frequency of the light e the
energy of each little chunk of light was
a new constant of nature called H times
the frequency H is cleverly now called
Planck's constant and it joins things
like the speed of light and Newton's
constant of gravity as a fundamental
feature of the natural world a
fundamental parameter of physics I will
tell you a little secret not much of a
secret but a little trick usually in
physics we define the angular frequency
Omega so F the frequency is literally
how often things go up and down you
multiply by 2pi to turn that into an
angular frequency so Omega is 2 pi times
F that's the angular frequency and then
we define H bar to be H Planck's
constant that he invented divided by 2
pi so E is H bar Omega and this is a
very famous formula plunks little
formula and what plunk is saying
remember is that black bodies are giving
off light giving off radiation not as a
smooth wave but in chunks he didn't
quite go so far as to say that that's
because light is individual particles
that was Einstein Einstein came along
and said forget it not just blackbody
radiation but in other contexts in the
photoelectric effect for example light
comes out in these quanta because light
really is particles and so we now call
these particles of light we call them
photons another thing that the name
nomenclature came along later ok
so that's interesting but it was also
disturbing because you know literally
one of the greatest triumphs of 19th
century physics have been understanding
that light was a wave in the electrum I
medic field here's Einstein a plunk
saying well it has a light also has a
certain particle like kind of behavior
under certain circumstances and it
involves this new constant of nature
plunks constant and it has sort of a
quantum feeling quantum just meaning a
discrete unit of something okay so that
was in the back of everyone's mind that
is something that is going on that was
fact number one light has particle-like
properties fact number two that people
began to discover matter like electrons
and atoms has wave-like properties or
field like properties if you want where
did that come from well remember this
picture that we had that we were putting
together of classical physics the the
world that could have been but it didn't
actually happen featured a bunch of
particles interacting with forces and
they came together to make atoms so it
was the Rutherford atom Nina Terence
Rutherford Rutter hoops that is the
famous picture you always see so the
Rutherford atom has you know protons and
neutrons in it there's proton to
neutrons and there are electrons
circling around in in orbits circles or
ellipses or whatever it's kind of like a
little solar system okay that's the
Rutherford atom and he got this
experimentally by shooting a little
helium nuclei at gold foil and seeing
that sometimes they recoil by a huge
amount as if the helium nuclei had hit
something small and dense and hard to
move namely what we now know as the
nucleus of the atom and this is a very
successful picture this is so successful
it's used basically as the symbol for
physics even today right the Rutherford
atom this famous picture the problem is
it can't be right we knew instantly that
this picture couldn't possibly be the
right answer why because we learned we
knew that if you take an electron and
move it it gives off electromagnetic
radiation that's what where light comes
from literally all the light around you
right now is coming from vibrating
electrons and in this Rutherford atom
you have electrons moving in circles to
beat the band that counts as moving okay
that counts as vibrating these electrons
should be giving off light so if I move
this over here this is the picture that
Rutherford thought was the case but what
actually should be the case is something
more like nucleus at the center protons
and neutrons and what the electron
should be doing is spiraling into the
center very very quickly why because as
the electron is moving it should be
giving off light it should be radiating
that's a terrible looking photon I just
drew there I can't really draw from
right to left very well so I'm gonna
draw it this way it's giving off photons
it's giving off light at all times it's
losing energy it's spiraling into the
middle so every atom in the universe if
Rutherford's model had been correct
should be wildly unstable how long does
it take for all the electrons to fall
into the center of the nucleus about 10
to the minus 11 seconds so 1/100 of a
billionth of a second so all the matter
in the universe including you and the
tables and earnst Rutherford etc should
be dramatically unstable that seems to
not be how things actually are so this
was a challenge this was a challenge to
this otherwise SuperDuper successful way
of thinking about particles and forces
and so forth what to do about it well
there were other clues that were clues
from how light is given off by gases
spectral lines and and so forth that led
Niels Bohr to suggest a modification of
the Rutherford atom Niels Bohr actually
served as basically postdoctoral
researcher in Rutherford's lab for a
little while and Bohr said that you have
the nucleus just like Rutherford thought
okay but rather than the electron being
just a particle that can be anywhere
there are certain allowed orbits that
the electron can be in and other orbits
is are just places where the electrons
are not allowed okay so the electron can
be there or it can be there but it can't
be in between that's just the rules why
because Niels Bohr said so this is circa
18:13 approximately and well you know
you might want to ask why is that true
and Bohr's answer was he didn't know yet
he was just making a guess like plunk
made for blackbody radiation you might
also say well what what orbits are
allowed okay the answer is if this is if
this distance is R the distance from the
nucleus to the electron then the angular
momentum of the electrons turns out if
you want to fit the data if you want to
understand the light that is given off
by these gases the angular momentum
which is given by just the ordinary
momentum P so you have some electron
moving here with a velocity and so it
has P equals MV momentum is mass times
velocity you can special relativity is
all this stuff if you want that's the
newtonian version P times R is the
angular momentum and board just says you
know what this quantity the angular
momentum of the electrons going in its
orbit is quantized because I said so and
what units is it quantized in it is n so
that's just some integer some number 1 2
3 4 etc times H times Planck's constant
so that's where you begin to think that
something miraculous is happening right
plunk came up with his constant by
saying that light which is supposed to
be a wave has particle-like properties
and you need to introduce a new constant
of nature to fit the data here Bohr is
saying that electrons a completely
different phenomenon have to be
quantized in a different way
only certain orbits are allowed but to
fit his data and to fit the data that he
cared about not the data he collected he
was a theorist but to fit the data that
he knew about the quantization condition
the chunkiness of which these electrons
had to participate was also
characterized by the same number as what
plunked him up with the same constant of
nature Planck's constant by the way you
might want to know you know what is the
number plunks constant it's some you
know some number of joules seconds
whatever it is I have no idea what it is
because every good physicist sets H bar
equal to 1 just like we set the speed of
light
equal to one and then we get on with our
lives because no one remembers how many
joules or whatever per second h-bar is
so we use much more sensible notation
than that and therefore in fact it's
almost impossible for me to remember
where the H bars go in almost any
equation so if I if I write down
equations and I forget the H bars that's
because in my brain they're set equal to
one okay so that's evidence that
something is going on I mean it seems
like a little clucky right little ad hoc
and it seems like you're doing violence
to the fundamental principles of
classical physics and that sounds bad
but it also seems to fit the data and it
was sort of nicely consonant with what
plunk and Einstein had said so that
sounds good but you still want to know
why something like this is true and the
answer came along from a couple people
the answer is basically that like we
said up here matter has wave-like
properties so the answer is that rather
than just thinking of the electron is a
little particle moving in a circular
orbit think of matter waves and the
first person to say this out loud was
Louis de Bruyne in his PhD thesis so you
know those are the standards for the PhD
thesis you're Louie de boy say electrons
are waves not particles okay and what he
says is you know very much like what
plunk said and Einstein for photons for
particles of light he said that you can
associate a wavelength with an electron
the wavelength lambda is the Devoy
wavelength and guess what it is H the
Planck's constant divided by P the
momentum so a fast moving particle has a
short debris wavelength
a slow moving particle is a very long
wavelength why why is this an
interesting thing to say well if you go
back up to Bohr's atom to Bohr's
condition the angular momentum has to be
a certain amount and you say well I'm
gonna interpret that as saying that when
the electron does an orbit there needs
to be an integer number of debris
wavelengths around the orbit okay then
you get fours quantization condition you
get it I'm not exactly sure I'm looking
at my notes here I didn't actually write
down these equations so I might get two
PI's in the wrong place
sorry about that but the point is that
if you just take the idea that an
electron has a wavelength and then you
say the only orbits for the electron
that are allowed are those that have an
integer number of wavelengths then you
naturally get that only certain orbits
are allowed others are not that fits the
data in exactly the way that Bohr had
wanted to so Bohr had this
phenomenological relationship right some
certain electron energies and orbits are
allowed certain ones are not Dubrow is
trying to explain it by saying the
reason why you get these energies is
because light because electrons are
waves so from both sides our classical
intuition is being attacked we thought
that matter was particles and we thought
that forces were fields and we're
realizing that matter has wave or field
like properties and and waves have
particle-like properties okay so it was
all put together I'm gonna again cuz
we're not being historical the first
really full-blown quantum mechanical
theory was called matrix mechanics it
came from Heisenberg born and Jordan and
physicists didn't like it like Einstein
said you know this is just mathematical
jiggery-pokery like I don't understand
what he's what they're saying this is
Einstein saying you know this to
mathematically complicated for me but
very soon after that picture came along
Schrodinger comes along with his picture
of quantum mechanics and it turns out to
be equivalent Schrodinger and Dirac and
others show that these two ways of doing
quantum mechanics are equivalent but
Schrodinger's way is just much more
comfortable to physicists because it's a
story of waves not of matrices matrices
are mathematical objects their physical
meaning was not very clear Schrodinger
comes along with waves and physicists
knew what to do with that they were very
happy with the idea of waves so
furniture says that we should have these
things called wave functions and he
didn't even as it turns out the way that
he thought about it wasn't exactly the
right way early on but still we we keep
the idea and he had an equation the
Schrodinger equation which tells us how
the wave functions evolve
so what is that what is going on what's
the difference here I mean Deroy says
electrons or waves but he didn't give a
dynamical equation for how those waves
evolve if you would ask you know how do
two electrons bump into each other and
scatter off he wouldn't have been able
to tell you that okay the classical
paradigm that we've been working with
before is given juice by this idea that
if you tell me the positions and
velocities of everything in the world
the Newton's laws or Hamilton's
equations or the principle of least
action or whatever will tell you how to
move them forward in time how to evolve
them in time that's the kind of equation
you want to turn these ideas into a
full-blown physical theory so that's
what Schrodinger gave us and also what
Heisenberg and born in Troodon gave us
they gave us a way of taking initial
conditions and being a quantum version
of Laplace's demon of saying from those
initial conditions what happens next
so schrödinger's wave function capital
sy the Greek letter saw is a typical way
of writing it so for just one particle
let's just take one electron we'll make
the world more complicated later on so
it's a function of where the electron
could be and when so it looks very much
like a field on space time but there's
subtleties that we'll get to which is
why we don't call it a field we call it
a wave function that's what it is or the
quantum state so aka also known as the
quantum state and just as a mathematical
fact at any one point the wave function
is a complex number so this is a real
number plus an imaginary number
imaginary numbers are proportional to I
which equals the square root of minus 1
so you're gonna see i's square root of
minus 1 all over the place in quantum
mechanics because the schrödinger's wave
a wave function is a complex valued
thing I'm not gonna get into any of
those mathematical details but you
should know that that's how it works ok
and what Schrodinger says is I'm going
to describe the electron as a wave this
complex-valued wave function I will tell
you what equation it obeys and to tell
you that equation
I need to remind you of the Hamiltonian
remember the hamiltonian the Hamiltonian
in classical mechanics H is a function
of X and P so you give me the position
and the velocity and for some physical
system the Hamiltonian tells you how
much energy it has right so in quantum
mechanics you don't have X and P you
have the wave function so remember X in
this when I say here X that is any
location in space that the particle
could be subjunctive Li right and P is
any momentum that it could have I can
assign by the Hamiltonian and energy to
that particular state in quantum
mechanics the state is not a particle
with a position and a velocity it's a
wave function okay that is the state so
this sigh of X and T replaces X and P
here okay so we want to know what the
Hamiltonian is of the wave function okay
not of a position and a momentum so what
sort of your figured out how to do that
okay basically and we don't need to go
into the details there's there's some
math involved some derivatives some
calculus as you might guess and fertig
ER said in quantum mechanics you should
treat the Hamiltonian as an operator so
we put the little hat on it to indicate
that it's an operator what that means is
rather than just evaluating and getting
a number you act it on the wave function
to get a different function so you give
the Hamiltonian sorry you give the wave
function Phi of X all over space
evolving through time but you just give
it to me at one moment of time okay so
sigh of X the hamiltonian says I'm going
to act on it I'm going to operate on it
and give you a new function okay and
then Schrodinger gives you some Mathieu
facts about how that happens and then he
sets that equal to I square root of -1
h-bar plunks constant the reduced Punk's
constant H over 2 pi times the
derivative of sy with respect to time d
sy DT and this is the funny DS of
partial differentiation that we talked
about before so this is Schrodinger's
equation in its most general form
a bunch of details in the letter capital
H here in what the Hamiltonian is every
physical system will have a different
Hamiltonian just like in classical
mechanics okay but the point is this is
an equation that answers the question
you give me the state namely sy the
wavefunction this equation tells me how
it evolves in time so this is the
equation that is being solved by a
quantum version of Laplace's daemon this
is the equation that tells you how the
trajectory of the wavefunction travels
through the universe through time cool
that sounds good now once you have an
equation its full employment for
physicists right you can just solve that
equation you can give it as homework to
your students boy does that happen a lot
because there's a lot of very
interesting situations you might want to
say okay solve this equation for an
electron in a hydrogen atom that's
actually pretty easy to do solve it for
two electrons in a helium atom turns out
to be really hard because the two
electrons are bumping into each other in
some way but you can do it okay again
full-employment
you can in principle answer whatever
question you have that's the usefulness
of this equation what it doesn't tell us
is what is Sai you know how should we
interpret it what - how should we think
of this wave traveling through space
after all didn't we have good reasons to
think of electrons as particles in the
first place now you can't just say well
no they're not particles they're waves
you have to explain to me why I should
believe that and why they ever looked
like particles in the first place so the
first step is I mean after all let me
also mention one interesting thing the
whole business about the Bohr atom and
the blackbody radiation and all that
stuff seemed to be a story of taking
smooth continuous things and making them
discrete right chunking them up that's
where the word quantum comes from in
quantum mechanics and here in the
Schrodinger equation you have a wave
function that is smooth and continuous
and you have an equation that says how
it smoothly evolves through time
there's nothing chunky or pixelated or
discreet about this at all where does
that come from the answer is I'm going
to
good a job I'm going to do with this but
I'll try to explain what the answer is
the answer is you solve this equation
for what the wave function of electron
is doing when the electron is sitting
close to the nucleus of an atom okay if
the electron is just out there in the
middle of space then there's nothing
quantum about it there's nothing
quantized discrete pixelated you can
have any energy move it any direction
the wave function be spread out all over
but basically when you put it in a box
which you can think of the the nucleus
as doing then the discreteness shows up
imagine you literally have a box so this
is just an analogy okay box analogy and
you have some oops
and you have I don't know what to say in
here let's say you have a string
attached to two different sides of the
box so the box isn't doing much except
holding together the two ends of the
string
now you can vibrate the string the
string is analogous to the wave function
okay the height of the string is Sai of
X and you can pluck it like a violin
string or a guitar string and it will
vibrate but you know that there are sort
of different vibrational modes allowed
so there's one mode where it just goes
up and down in a simple way like that
okay
but there's another mode where it sort
of has twice the frequency and half the
wavelength and there's another mode
where it has three times the frequency
and so forth okay so the point of these
little pictures are that the solutions
to the vibrational states of the string
given that we have tied it down on both
ends come in a discrete set there's the
lowest wavelength that sorry the longest
wavelength half that 1/3 of that etc the
electron near the nucleus of the atom is
like that it's not quite in a box but
it's snuggled down there near the
nucleus it's being held in there by the
electromagnetic force its wave function
tapers to zero very very far away and so
the allowed wave functions that solve
Schrodinger's equation for an electron
near the
nucleus of an atom are discrete there is
a lowest energy one one of one higher
energy one higher energy than that etc
and you can go through and you can
derive the Bohr atom you can derive
these conditions that the momentum will
only have the angular momentum only has
these certain values that you can derive
dubrow's wavelength versus momentum
relationship all of that comes out of
the Schrodinger equation but the
quantumness of it is not because nature
is fundamentally discrete or pixelated
it's because when you solve this wave
equation in a box or near the nucleus of
an atom you get a discrete set of
solutions okay that's where the quantum
this comes from so Schrodinger with his
wave equation is able to reproduce the
successes of the Bohr atom with the
discrete orbits and things like that
what about the fact that electrons look
like particles so we can do the
following thing this is that was our
analogy so now let's look at electrons
so we don't need to just think about
them sitting in atoms we can take a
little electron gun cathode ray tube
that is shooting out electrons and we
can look at them this is like a cloud
chamber cloud chamber is a physics
experiment where you use sort of super
saturate a gas and then you shoot
charged particles through it and they
make little bubbles or little clouds
there's also bubble chambers which are
slightly different but the same spirit
that leave tracks and if you put in a
magnetic field and the particles with
different charges will be deflected in
different directions etc and the point
is you can go online you can look at
pictures of particles in cloud chambers
or bubble chambers or modern particle
detectors at the Large Hadron Collider
at CERN for example when you shoot
electrons into a detector like this they
leave tracks which doesn't sound
surprising what else would you expect it
to do well tracks are something you
would expect a particle to leave but
Schrodinger and deployer saying that
electrons are really waves is that the
actual prediction you would make for a
way
no the wave would spread out all over
the place you'd see some big puffy cloud
and it turns out that this is just one
example but there's many more examples
when you actually look at electrons you
never see waves you never see these big
puffy clouds you see particle-like
behavior Schrodinger himself hoped that
something like this would happen the
hope the Schrodinger had was that if you
started with an electron wave function
so here's space and you had an electron
wave function sigh like this that it
would naturally evolve over time into
something that was more concentrated in
other words that the wave function
electron in empty space was sort of
naturally narrow and begin to look more
and more point like and that would
explain why electrons look like points
just because they're waves but they're
waves that are really concentrated near
one point sadly this does not happen at
all it's the opposite if you start with
Schrodinger's equation with a little
wave packet and just let it go in empty
space it spreads out all over the place
so we're a little bit stuck and this is
why you need to think start thinking
about interpretations of quantum
mechanics it seems very very naively
that the following thing is going on
that when you're not looking at the
electrons when the electrons are just
sitting there in atoms and you want to
explain their energy levels and stuff
like that when you're not looking at
them the electrons are behaving like
waves and when you look at them they
behave like particles that seems to be
what's going on but that's crazy because
clearly whether or not we're looking at
something should not be part of the
fundamental nature of reality right that
shouldn't be part of our best theories
of physics so the greatest minds in the
history of physics came together and
decided that the right way of thinking
about this was to say that when we're
not looking at the electron it's a wave
and when we look at it it's a particle
this is this is what we teach our
students to this day and some people
like Einstein and Freud anger never
liked this idea but nevertheless this is
this is what we say so this is the
Copenhagen interpretation
of quantum mechanics and I say that only
with some trepidation because no one
really agrees and what the Copenhagen
interpretation is you know we attributed
to Niels Bohr and friends but Heisenberg
was just as influential and in fact like
the first step in this direction
probably could be credited to Max Born
who's Heisenberg's collaborator but the
idea is that we need an extra set of
rules in physics so if you if you do
classical physics you do Newtonian
physics whether it's fields or particles
or whatever you have two ingredients you
have the system which is described by a
point in phase space its positions and
velocities and then you had the
dynamical equations at the equals MA or
Hamilton's equations or whatever and
that's it you stop in quantum mechanics
in the Copenhagen interpretation you
have two different sets of rules the
first set of rules is you have a state
in the state is the wave function for
daggers functions Cybex and T and you
have an equation telling you how that
wave function evolves the Schrodinger
equation it's exactly parallel to
classical mechanics but then in the
Copenhagen interpretation in what I'm
calling the Copenhagen interpretation
what you might want to call the textbook
or or usual conventional interpretation
of quantum mechanics
there's a new set of rules and the new
set of rules only has to do with what
happens when you observe or measure a
system the rules of quantum mechanics
that we teach ourselves have a whole
separate category for measurements and
the outcomes of measurements unlike any
other theory of physics and you know I'm
not saying anything controversial here
this is what you can find in everyone's
quantum mechanics textbook the
controversy comes in when you try to say
well what's really going on when you do
these measurements but for right now
that's not where we are in this video
that's for later contemplations right
now I'm just telling you what the rules
are okay
there are basically three rules one rule
is let me let me actually just say this
is for when you measure or observe a
quantum mechanical system
rule one is you see definite outcomes
and I'm trying to translate some very
specific mathematical formalism into
everyday language here the point is you
can measure something you call the
position of the electron you can ask the
question where is the electron you can
shoot it through a cloud chamber and
look to see where it is and the first
rule of quantum mechanical observations
is you see it somewhere you never see it
spread out all over the place okay you
can think of this wave function Phi of X
as attaching a different value to every
possible place the electron could be
seen and the wave function might be
completely spread out but when you see
it you see it somewhere you see some
definite outcome for that measurement of
course if you you never in the real
world have perfect measuring precision
right you never have a an infinitely
good measuring apparatus so there's
always some uncertainty about the
measurement outcome but that uncertainty
is not the famous uncertainty principle
okay
even in classical physics your measuring
apparatus is never perfect that's not
the point the point is if you had a
perfect measuring apparatus you would
see a definite place where the electron
is that's the first extra rule the
second extra rule is you cannot predict
from what that outcome will be with
perfect fidelity all you can do is say
the probability of getting a different
measurement outcome so the probability
of a measurement outcome is given by a
very simple formula remember the wave
function psy is a complex number so we
want to take its length we're going to
square it and that means square the real
part square the imaginary part and add
them together the notation we use is we
put bars around it so we take psy and we
ask what is the value of the wave
function associated with that
measurement outcome okay so you see what
I'm doing here I said that I was a
function of position that's one way of
talking about size one way of talking
about the wavefunction there are other
ways of talking about it which we'll get
to in a second but the point is if we
want to measure the position we say well
okay what is the value of the wave
function at every individual position
and the probability of seeing it at that
position is the wave function squared
this is the famous born rule after Max
Born Max born is not Niels Bohr those
are two different people so it was born
Max Born who said that's what
schrödinger's wave function is okay it
is a way of calculating the probability
of seeing the electron doing different
things it is not sort of something that
you have direct access to observational
E and this is the part that Schrodinger
had not anticipated and didn't really
like okay but it is this is what we
teach our students and then after
observation afterward by making this
observation you have changed the
wavefunction dramatically you get what
is called wavefunction collapse after
the new sy equals one at that outcome
that you saw and zero for any other
outcome this is called collapse of the
wavefunction what does that mean so in
pictures what this means is if before
you've made a measurement you had
position and you have some wave function
like this sigh and then you measure it
capital sine let's say you measure it
and you see that it's here that's the
outcome you actually get in your
experiment then after you do your
experiment the wave function is not that
anymore here's what the wave function
was here's what the weight and here's
where you saw it and here's what the
wave function is now by one I mean it is
completely localized at that particular
measurement outcome it's not really the
number one
yes the integral of the wave function
has to give you the number one not not
the actual value of the wave function
but you get the point the wave function
goes from being all spread out to
collapsing on to the value that you saw
and you can't predict ahead of time
exactly what it was all you can predict
is where the wave function is bigger
there's a higher probability of getting
that outcome where it's smaller there's
a lower probability so these are the
rules the extra rules dealing with
measurement and observation in quantum
mechanics okay this is why quantum
mechanics is weird and hard and
controversial because no other theories
of physics have these new sets of rules
for the outcome of measurements okay
it seems that quantum mechanics is
trying to say that there is a
fundamental divide between what nature
really is and what you see when you look
at it it seems and I keep saying scenes
cuz not everyone's gonna agree okay but
the most straightforward way of
interpreting this is the electron is a
wave when you're not looking at it but
you never see the way if you see a
particle the things that you see the set
of possible outcomes for measurements
are fundamentally different than the
reality behind the scenes when you're
not looking at it okay that is the
Copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics so this is this is complicated
and and controversial for all sorts of
reasons there's a very obvious reason
let me mention two reasons why this
might be problematic I'm not gonna
answer these questions but here are the
two problems problem one is the
measurement problem by which I mean come
on what do you mean when you measure
something like what what is that
supposed to tell me what counts as a
measurement Duany can I do with my
eyeballs do I need a microscope I eat a
cloud chamber can my cats do
measurements can like insects in the
room do measurements can a video camera
do a measurement what about an atom can
that do a measurement what if I only
look at it a little bit does the
wavefunction still collapse you know you
haven't told me how quickly measurements
happen what kind of interactions
counters measurements
and if you ask if you're you know an
undergraduate taking quantum mechanics
and you ask these questions you're told
to stop asking those questions that is
not what the Copenhagen interpretation
tells you now there are people who want
to be more respectable and one of the
sort of try to answer those questions
but fundamentally the measurement
problem is number one measurement plays
a crucial role in the rules of quantum
mechanics number two we haven't defined
what we mean by measurement that's the
measurement problem and that's an issue
here's the other problem that I like to
highlight that sort of gets swept under
the rug sometimes the reality problem
now I spoke in ways like I said I was I
hesitated sometimes along the way here
because not everyone agrees I spoke in a
way that made it sound like the electron
really was a wave when you're not
looking at it that in other words the
wavefunction sigh schrödinger's wave
function really is the electron when
you're not looking at it but you don't
see it you never see sigh you only see
different measurement outcomes like the
position so is it really true that sigh
is reality or is is schrödinger's wave
function just a tool that we use for
calculating the likelihood of certain
measurement outcomes is side just a
black box is it possible there are some
other ways of characterizing quantum
mechanical States which if we knew what
they were would give us definite
outcomes for quantum measurements that's
what people like Einstein and also you
know Dubrow and other people really
hoped was going to be true other people
say you know so there's there's the idea
that there's hidden variables in some
sense other variables that are not
included in this discussion that would
if only we knew them give us exactly
what the measurement outcome was going
to be that was sort of the Einsteinian
de Broglie and point of view David Bohm
invented a theory like that later on
there's the Copenhagen point of view
which says don't talk to me about
reality don't worry about reality who
cares reality we don't care about that
we care about them observational
outcomes we care about what we see okay
that's a different philosophy there's
you get a third philosophy that says
actually let's face the music let's
imagine that the wavefunction really
is reality okay that's the one that I
tend to like myself which is why I tend
to talk that way but I want you to know
that there are people who disagree so
and let me let me drive home how
important that is remember you know we
were talking about these atoms and we
said you know there was the Bohr model
okay or the the Rutherford model the
Bohr model where the electrons were in
little orbits and electrons are really
tiny little things so in this picture
that we drew you can make the statement
that atoms are mostly empty space right
because there you go you know that you
look at the size of the electron which
is basically zero the size of the
nucleus which is not quite zero but
still pretty small and mostly it's empty
space in between the problem with that
is if you believe in quantum mechanics
you shouldn't believe that the electron
is a little dot moving in an orbit okay
you should know better than that
what you should do is imagine if
anything if we know anything at all
let's see if I can actually do this yeah
we should imagine as the electron is
sort of in a cloud maybe a little bit
more likely to be nearby okay but the
wave function of the electron is
actually the best way to talk about the
electron and that's spread out all over
the place so if you believe that the
wave function represents reality then
you don't say that atoms are mostly
empty space atoms are mostly the wave
function of the electron the electron
wave function takes up space in the atom
that's why atoms have a size at all
so even such a simple straightforward
question like or atoms mostly empty
space or not we don't know the answer to
that or at least we don't agree on what
the answer is some of us have ideas to
what the answer is but people don't
agree so you shouldn't make very
definitive statements about it okay but
let me just that's the basic story of
quantum mechanics but let me kind of
emphasize some of the features that come
along with this story I talked about
observational outcomes right so things
like in in quantum mechanics things like
position I don't need to write things
like position
momentum etc don't you're gonna some
people gonna give me a hard time for
this but they don't can you guess what
the next word is exist what do I mean by
that I mean you know of course you can
measure the position of an electron I
already told you you could do that but
that's the point these things like
position of momentum they are
observational outcomes they're possible
observational outcomes so in quantum
mechanics there are things you can
observe and things you can't ah
I have not improved my ability to write
and talk at the same time sorry about
that
things you observe things you can there
are outcomes you can possibly get like
the position of an electron you can ask
what answer do I get when I measure the
position of the electron so we say that
position is an observable it's a thing
that can be observed and you can have
outcomes and the wave function gives you
the probability of getting all the
different observational outcomes but if
you want to say well when I'm not
looking at it okay when I the wave
function is some spread out thing what
is the position then and the best way of
thinking about I think this should be
true no matter what your favorite
interpretation of quantum mechanics is
the best way of thinking about is there
is no such thing as the position or the
momentum of the electron when you're not
observing it when you are observing it
you can ask the question where do I see
the position of the electron under where
do I measure how much do I measure the
momentum to be but it's not something
that has a definite existence when
you're not looking at it in the general
case so this is why quantum mechanics is
hard because intuitively no matter what
no matter how much formalism we've been
taught etcetera we tend to treat things
that we observe as real all right that's
the world that we're seeing there it is
and quantum mechanics is drawing this
distinction between what we see and what
is even things that are so tangible and
obvious and intuitive like the positions
of things
our only observational outcomes they are
not what really exists in this kind of
way of thinking leads to a very profound
and famous consequence called the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle okay so
you can have wave functions that are
very close to or even exactly definite
in some observational outcome so you can
imagine a wave function psy as a
function of X that looks like this as we
drew it before something that is very
very close to completely infinitely
peaked around some definite outcome and
then you could say well it's almost true
we're pretty darn close to true that
that particle has a location the X
naught in this particular case but then
you say okay well what is its momentum
and you have no idea what that is why is
that so what what is really going on
well it's because this is a wave
function of definite or pretty close to
definite position you can also think
about wave functions of definite or
pretty close to definite momentum but
they don't look anything like this the
wave function is not separately a
function of position and momentum right
remember I said the wave function is a
function of position you can figure out
what the momentum is by telling me what
the wave function is as a function of
position so if I have a wave function
that looks like a sine wave this is a
wave function of definite momentum and
that is completely compatible with this
is because this is where louis de bois
wavelength comes from right lambda the
de rooy wavelength was H over P the
momentum so there's this inverse
relationship between wavelength and
momentum if you have a wave function
that has a definite wavelength that is
just oscillating with a fixed wavelength
everywhere then it has a definite
momentum but to have a fixed wavelength
everywhere is the opposite of being
localized in space it turns out this is
a little bit deeper than you really need
to go but if you if you want so let's
think about when you turn on the radio
okay you turn on the radio or not
forgetting about the radio let's imagine
you're listening to music or listening
to sounds okay you can tell the
difference when you listen between a
high-pitched sound and a low pitch sound
notes of different pitches are things
that your ears can discriminate between
right even though what is actually
hitting your ears is just the density of
air at any one moment in time what's
happening is that the density of air is
oscillating up and down okay you could
plot the density of air near your ear
and it would be going up and down and
what your ear does is to separate out
contributions in the sound waves from
different pitches from different
wavelengths from different frequencies
of oscillation so there is a wonderful
mathematical thing called Fourier
analysis oops I missed a letter sorry
mr. fool yang a lot of people named
Fourier actually so Fourier analysis is
the thing that says any function f of X
can be written
as a combination of functions with
definite wavelengths so this is what
your brain and ears are doing all the
time they are taking a function what is
the pressure of air at your ear as a
function of time and they are writing it
they are separating it out into a bunch
of different notes a bunch of different
wavelengths corresponding to different
pitches of the music or the sound that
you're listening to and this is possible
because of Fourier analysis Fourier
transforms they sometimes D called okay
so in other words let's say you have
some function f of X and it looks like
you know it's small and then it sort of
vibrates a little bit and does something
like that there's X so you can write
that as something with a long wavelength
plus something with a slightly shorter
wavelength plus something with an even
shorter wavelength etc I'm not drawing
these perfectly but all these are
supposed to be perfect sine waves with
absolutely definite wavelengths okay and
this is called the Fourier transform and
so this is you know well let's let's
just say it we can take f of X in fact
let's say let's just be very blatantly
on point here you can take the wave
function
psy is a function at X right that's the
schrödinger's wave function and you can
Fourier transform it as we say to write
it as psy as a function of P the
momentum because these things of
definite wavelengths are roughly
speaking parts of the wave function with
definite momentum now this point that we
made up here is that if you are of
definite position or pretty close you
are not a definite wavelength and
therefore not a definite momentum
likewise if you're of definite momentum
a smooth curve
sine-wave then you are not a definite
position so therefore there are no wave
functions with the property that you
know ahead of time when you measure the
position what you will get and when you
know ahead of time when you measure the
momentum what what you will get you can
do something that is pretty close you
can have a wave function that is close
to being localized in both position of
momentum if it sort of looks like this
right so it's zero to the left zero to
the right Wiggles around a little bit
and there is some sort of variation here
that is not exactly located in position
but there's a certain uncertainty if you
want to call it that if you were to
measure the position it would be within
that band Delta X and if you did the
Fourier transform to write this little
oscillating wave packet as a sum of
momenta it'll be pretty close to this P
here this is approximately the
wavelength okay of this particular wave
but it's not exactly it's really a sum
of different things and so Heisenberg
comes along and says that he formalizes
mathematically this fact that you cannot
both be localized in position and
momentum as Delta x times Delta P is
always greater than equal to H bar over
2 there's details you have to worry
about here but the reason why I'm doing
this is because there's one emphasize to
you that this has nothing to do with
measurement all by itself okay
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle is
not the statement that you disturb a
quantum system when you measure it that
statement was already made that that
savings in the collapse of the
wavefunction before okay
Heisenberg's statement is a statement
about all the possible wave functions
you can imagine the momentum in the
position are not things that exist they
are possible measurement outcomes okay
and Heisenberg statement says that no
matter what wavefunction you imagine it
can't be one where you will know ahead
of time both the position and the
momentum that's what this is saying it
says nothing - it's disturbing it but
disturbing it is part of what quantum
mechanics actually says ok
I think we should I think we should call
it there I have many more things to say
but that's okay I've planned ahead of
time this is only going to be one out of
I'm gonna try to squeeze the rest of the
fundamentals of quantum mechanics into
another lecture into another video
hopefully next week but this is the
basic story and you can see why things
are tricky okay this is this is why
things are tricky right here because we
need to talk about observations and
measurements when we do quantum
mechanics we don't know what that means
that's a problem
and we don't even know what the reality
that we're actually describing is
there's a sense in which generations of
physicists have been more or less
brainwashed into thinking that they
shouldn't care about what reality is
that all they should care about are the
outcomes of measurements okay Steven
Weinberg the famous physicist and one of
my absolute heroes in physics you know
among all the living physicists right
now he's someone I admire as much as
anybody and he wrote a textbook on
general relativity where he makes this
attitude very explicit he's talked about
general relativity not quantum mechanics
but it carries over he says all this
talk about curved space-time and stuff
like that who cares I don't care about
that stuff what I care about is making
predictions for where spectral lines
will appear or you know photons will hit
photographic plates and things like that
and as much as I admire them I could not
disagree more about that in my view
physics is about understanding reality
no you know twelve-year-old girl gets
excited about physics because she says
someday I will grow up to make
predictions about observational outcomes
what they get interested in is the cool
stuff that we learned about the real
universe and quantum mechanics is a
place where we haven't yet figured out
what the science is trying to teach us
about the real universe what reality is
actually is that what the reality
actually is that we are describing with
our formalism of quantum mechanics so we
have to do better we're trying we're not
there yet
tune in next week maybe we'll make some
progress